our main story tonight is unfortunately
continuing coverage of the 2016 election
or as it's better known lice on rats on
a horse corpse on fire 2016 this
election has now achieved a dubious
distinction Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump are among the most disliked
presidential candidates in history so it
is hardly surprising that some are
seeking an alternative who's your vote
for right now I really don't like either
candidate to be honest Marlee excited
about the election I just don't really
feel like I like either option
Republicans and Democrats are kind of
bumming me out
315 320 million people and this is the
best tool that we can come up with it's
true Americans are so disillusioned by
the major party candidates you've seen
many would prefer to vote for Kevin
Klein's character from the movie Dave or
the ghost of Martin Luther King jr.
Asumi he only said the three quotes that
white people like and this this
disenchantment may explain the high
interest in America's third parties
because when your two main options are
depressing any third choice seems good
if you're an if you're a KFC Taco Bell
and you see a bunch of pigeons eating
something in the parking lot you might
well think hang on what if they got over
there and luckily there are a great many
third-party options out there there's
Jim hedges of the prohibition party the
worst party without alcohol since you
are born-again cousin's wedding there's
Dan paycheck of illegal marijuana and
now party which had really because the
illegal marijuana now legal marijuana
ASAP party and then there's independent
write-in candidates Joe exotic who
claims to run the world's largest
private zoo for Tigers and produces
incredible campaign videos first thing
is I'm not cutting my hair I'm not
changing the way I dress over fuse to
wear a suit I am gay I've had two
boyfriends most of my life I'm broke as
I have a judgment against me from
some down there in Florida and
this is all paid for by the committee of
Joe exotic speaks for America
Wow just wow
Joe exotic is truly the candidate you'd
want to sit down and have a beer with
then another beer and then several more
beers until you're drunk enough to try
meth for the first time the point is Joe
exotic make America exotic again but the
best known of the lesser known
candidates are clearly libertarian Gary
Johnson and Green Party nominee Jill
Stein in a poll just last month more
than a third of young voters said they
are considering voting for one of them
so they are worth taking seriously and
before we go any further we should
probably address the common critique
that third party candidates can siphon
off votes and potentially wind up
electing an ideological opponent and
there is some historical precedent for
that from Teddy Roosevelt's 1912 run
which arguably helped to elect Democrat
Woodrow Wilson to Ralph Nader in 2000
winning nearly a hundred thousand votes
in Florida estate which Al Gore famously
lost by just 537 but third parties are a
little touchy about that whole spoiler
tag just watch Gary Johnson respond
after it's brought up then it is just
this is just it's horrible why would you
even say that we're giving people a
chance to vote for something as opposed
to the lesser of two evils
we're not spoilers we are the first vote
so I guess we should drop out is that
what you're saying is that is that your
editorial here okay Gary just just relax
a little bit you you've already undercut
your credentials as a serious candidate
by wearing a yellow tie with geez come
on Gary you're running for president not
officiating pikachu's beach wedding
although to be fair
Johnson's anger is understandable just
dismissing third party candidates and
spoilers shuts down debate and while the
argument that the only thing that stops
Trump is a vote for Hillary Clinton is a
powerful one so is the argument that
people should vote for the candidate who
most closely shares their values
so let's vet these candidates not as
spoilers or as protest votes but as
legitimate potential presidents and
we'll start with Jill Stein the
candidate who looks most like she
believes Carib is just as good as
chocolate
now Stein is currently polling around 2%
and she has a lot going for her she's a
doctor who practiced internal medicine
for 27 years and she has a broadly
appealing pitch from environmental
issues to expanding LGBTQ rights to
reducing income inequality but when it
comes to policy we all know the devil is
in the details so how exactly is she
going to accomplish her goals and let's
start with the plan that has been
central to her candidacy we're the one
party that's actually calling for
canceling student debt and bailing out a
generation of young people like we
bailed out the bankers on Wall Street we
can do that for this generation and
unleash them to be the stimulus package
of our dreams okay hold on because
stimulus package of your dreams
sounds like how Paul Krugman describes
his penis but but but she is right
student debt is a massive 1.3 trillion
dollar problem canceling it is Stein's
flagship proposal it is to her campaign
what the border wall is to Donald
Trump's so you would assume that she has
a well-thought-out coherent plan my
campaign is the only one that will do
for young people what our miss leaders
saw fit to do for Wall Street not that
long ago it was about four trillion in
free money in the form of so-called
quantitative easing which is a magic
trick that basically people don't need
to understand anymore about and that it
is a magic trick no it isn't though it
is a very complicated monetary policy
tool and while it might not be important
for most people to understand it you
certainly have to and I don't think you
do because for a start while Jill Stein
has said the president has the authority
to cancel student debt using
quantitative easing that is absolutely
wrong the President does not have that
authority only the Federal Reserve does
and it does not take Marting orders from
the White House because that would be
extremely dangerous you don't want to
give presidents the power to just create
new money whenever they want to think of
it all this if Joe xotic is elected you
don't want him to be able to order the
Fed to create money for the most lavish
tiger themed orgy the nation has
because they would then have to print
the $3,500 it would take to do that so
that issue alone makes our plan a
non-starter before we even get into the
fact that quantitative easing does not
apply here Stein is implying that it was
used to cancel banks debts and that is
absolutely not what it did using in a
way that she's describing amounts to a
president unilaterally passing a new law
and funding it by printing new money and
the the dangers of that should be pretty
obvious in terms of how fundamentally
flawed that is on every level
it's basically akin to saying I'll make
us energy independence by ordering the
post office to invade Canada no-till
that's impractical it's a terrible idea
and you don't seem to understand
anything about it when I first her
student debt proposal was her version of
Donald Trump's border wall I meant it
because the only way it could be any
more unlikely is if she claimed Mexico
was somehow going to pay for it and for
a candidate who seems to be running on
principle it can be hard to pin her down
on what those principles are after the
EU brexit vote her campaign issued a
statement in which she called the
decision a victory before changing it to
read I agreed with the UK Greens who
supported staying in the EU and in
response to charges that she was
anti-vaccination she tweeted there's no
evidence that autism is caused by
vaccines before Jill Stein a doctor
remember replaced it with a more
equivocal I'm not aware of evidence
linking autism with vaccines leaving the
door open for doubt and Qing measles and
this strategic business even applies to
answering a question from a 9/11 truther
I believe that the hijackers were
patsies they did have intent but there
was no ways they could fly those planes
the way they did and there's no willing
way those steel buildings could fall the
way you have an opinion about that so I
think we need the full story and the
9/11 Commission itself said we don't
have the full story so I would simply
bring back that Commission this isn't
this isn't controversial in my view it's
time to get the full story what are you
doing
you know that man thinks you just agreed
with him now right
you can't just hear a conspiracy theory
fan the flames and then walk away is
Katy Perry JonBenet Ramsey well identity
theft is a real and persistent issue in
this day and age and we really need to
look into that and if none of what I've
said bothers you that's fine I mean it's
it's not really fine but that is your
right but you are also going to need to
co-sign on one more awkward thing and
that is that Jill Stein recorded several
albums as part of a 90's folk rock band
called somebody's sister and you don't
get to not hear what they sound like
[Music]
[Applause]
Jill Jill that is a very bad song for a
start silent thunder is nothing you're
describing silence and and I frankly
cannot have a president who's going to
play her own inauguration with a band
that sounds like the Indigo Girls
fronting the Red Hot Chili Peppers so
for now let's move on to Gary Johnson
the two-term governor of New Mexico and
the man who in most photographs seems to
be around 80% sure that he is running
for president so he has been polling
around 6% nationally which is pretty
remarkable given that his race has been
largely notable for moments like not
knowing what Aleppo is not being able to
name a world leader he admires and
whatever it is that he's doing here do
you think if you were able to get on the
debate stage that you could pull even I
think I could stand up there for a whole
day and not say anything and I'm loose
as well I'm not sure if he was doing
that with his tongue on purpose or if
Gary Johnson's tongue just decided it
I'm done and tried to escape through his
mouth but obviously law to Gary Johnson
than just mistakes for instance he is an
avid outdoorsman who loves mountain
climbing so much he was described
summiting Mount Everest like this people
ask me gosh what was it like to conquer
Mount Everest well I did not conquer
Mount Everest she lifted her skirt and I
got in there and got a beak and it was
really cool
okay okay I'm still a little confused
here did you actually climb Mount
Everest or did you just dry-hump the
side of it and then go home it was great
now smell my finger there's still some
mountain air on it what is wrong with
you now now as for his policies as with
Jill Stein there is a lot to like there
he supports marijuana legalization and
opposes the death penalty civil
forfeiture and police militarization but
scratch beneath the surface and there
are some positions you may be less
comfortable with frozen sea opposes
having a minimum wage and when he says
he's for smaller government he's not
kidding around governors could you name
three federal departments or agencies
that you would eliminate uh education
the Department of Commerce and Housing
and Urban Development how's that for
starters oh there he's giving up
government agencies left and right this
is Sophie's Choice if she hated all of
her children take both kids
I'm sick of stepping on Legos off you go
but but to be fair that is an
intellectually consistent position but
now watch him fold under the slightest
pressure would any of their functions
still be performed by the federal
government gosh if and you'd have to
assume that they were doing something
that was of value and yeah if they are
doing something of value yes we would we
would be looking to continue those
operations those departments all do a
lot of stuff you can't identify any
specific things they did here you're
asking you're asking three departments
and I'm giving them to you right but
then you take the assumption that they
should be a little with okay for the
record and this is probably obvious
those three departments do actually do
things of value assuming that you find
Pell grants mortgage insurance
low-income housing programs the National
Weather Service the Patent and Trademark
Office and the Census Bureau to be of
some value and if it comes as news to
you that that's what those departments
do well then hi Gary
I'm excited you're watching the show
quick piece of advice please stop trying
to Fountains and again again like Jill
Stein Johnson is prone to overly simple
solutions that could have disastrous
consequences just look at how he applies
his small-government approach to tax
policy if I could wave a magic wand I
would eliminate income tax I would
eliminate corporate tax I would abolish
the IRS and I would replace it all with
one federal consumption tax come on Gary
you have a magic wand and the first
thing you do is eliminate income tax
with it
shame on you the first thing anyone
should do is make soap tastes as good as
it smells and you don't judge me it's
not the only thing that I would do it's
just the first thing I would do magical
simple plan gets complicated very fast
because Johnson says his consumption tax
would be between 23 and 28 percent on
almost everything you buy and that could
clearly hurt poor people the most so his
answer is that every single home in
America would receive a pre-baked check
each month covering the cost of the
sales tax up to around the poverty line
but when a presidential advisory panel
studied a similar proposal a decade ago
they found that it's not just that
simple aside from the complexity of the
pre-baked program which by the way would
become America's largest entitlement
program ever for this policy to work
they suggested these sales tax would
have to be way more than 28% with the
burden falling heavily on the middle
class and to avoid all that they might
have to be savaged government cuts but
rather than honestly admit that Johnson
tries to wriggle out of the subject the
big problem with doing what you're doing
is you wind up cutting the amount of
revenues that governor government has to
work actually it's a revenue neutral the
whole the whole proposal that's not so
according economists that's not so easy
well then well maybe not your doing
Chris but by just to give you the
context why if you say the FairTax
number that's usually thrown out is 28%
this would be your consumption tax so
you're automatically reducing the 39%
from the top level down that creates an
issue about how you want to distribute
the tax burden you're writing a little
into into the we've figure what D
mean to in the weeds the only point of
discussing tax policy is to get into the
weeds that and preventing premature
ejaculation that's the two options and
if it can seem like Gary Johnson
occasionally just doesn't give a
maybe he doesn't because wait until you
hear his stance on combating climate
change should we take the long term view
and it comes to global warming I think
that we should and the long term view is
that in billions of years the Sun is
going to actually grow and encompass the
earth right so global warming is in our
in our future that's your plan
don't worry we'll all be dead eventually
anyway I guess we're just lucky that we
won't be around to see that day because
I do not want the last thing I hear to
be Gary Johnson saying the sun's not so
much conquered the earth it's merely
lifted up her skirt and finger-blasted
it no Gary why are you so weird the
point here is the more you look about
Gary Johnson and Jill Stein the more you
realize the lack of coverage they
complain about so much might have
genuinely benefited them because their
key proposals begin to crumble under the
slightest scrutiny and look I would love
for there to be a perfect third-party
candidate I even understand the argument
that a third-party candidate can put a
new issue or a new solution on the table
but it is hard to make the case that
that is what's happening here there is
no perfect candidate in this race and
when people say you don't have to choose
the lesser of two evils they are right
because you have to choose the lesser of
four anyone who goes into a voting booth
on November the eighth and comes out
saying I feel a hundred percent great
about what I just did in there is either
lying to themselves or did something
unspeakable in that booth
and that means as uncomfortable as this
is everyone has to own the floors of
whoever you vote for whether they are a
lying handsy narcissistic sociopath a
hawkish Wall Street friendly embodiment
of everything that some people can't
stand about politics an ill-tempered
mountain molester with a radical
dangerous tax plan that even he can't
defend or a conspiracy pandering
political neophyte with no clear
understanding of how government operates
and who once recorded this folk rap
about the virtues of bicycling I feel
like we just figured out who or what
killed Biggie and Tupac and and before
you say well hold on John there is one
perfect candidate that you haven't
mentioned yet I will remind you he's
broke his and he will not wear a
suit